لكلمه لممثل السياسه الخارجيه اذا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل
وعلى مر السنه راينا جميعا
شجاعه الاوكرانيين نصره لبلادهم وهم
يستحقون التضامن من الجميع عبر العالم من
كل دوله ومن كل شخص
وددو ان
ركز على نقطتين اثنتين اليوم
لماذا تعنين هذه الحرب التي اختارتها
روسيا وثانيا كيف
نصل الى السنه
دعونا دعونا نكون واضحين قلت حربا
اختارتها روسيا حرب خيار لان هذه الحرب هي
حرب الرئيس بوتين هو الذي اختار الحرب
وعلى مر سنه راينا الفضائع 13 مليون مشرد
21 مليون يحتاجون المساعده الانسانيه
وعشرات الاف الاوكرانيين يجبرون على ترك
ديارهم والبحث عن ملاجئ في اوروبا
مزقه الاسر وفي طيف من الجرائم راينا
ترحيلا قصريا لعشرات الاف الاطفال
راينا اختطافا لاطفال اوكرانيين ابرياء مع
تغيير لوضعهم الشخصي بما في ذلك الجنسيه
حتى يتم تبنيهم من اسر روسيه وفي ذلك
انتهاك واضح لقانون حقوق الانسان والقانون
الدولي وفي ذلك انتهاك كذلك الاتفاقيات
الاطفال الاوكرانيون لابد من ان يعادوا
الى اوكرانيا فورا
ثم جرائم ضد الانسانيه انا زرت بوتشا
ورايت بامي العين مدنيين يقتلون
بعضهم مقيده يديهما